angelina jolie is one proud mama we are
just a family the actress shares her
pride on instagram revealing details
about daughter zahara's college plans
the 17 year old is heading to spelman
college this fall
zahara is the most organized in the
family she's growing up so beautifully
and it's clear she's already thriving on
campus angelina writes quote zahara with
her spelman sisters congratulations to
all new students starting this year
adding quote a very special place and an
honor to have a family member as the new
spelman girl
angelina ends a happy message with the
hashtag hbcu
a shout out to spelman's legacy as a
historically black college
zahara is one of the six children
estranged exes angelina and brad pitt
share
her siblings vivian knox shiloh pax and
maddox all make up the star-studded
family when your children are your best
friends it's kind of a it's a nice life
and zahara's announcement follows a
special moment for the mother and
daughter
the reason that many people struggle to
leave
abusive situations is that
they've been made to feel worthless
in february zahara supported angelina in
washington dc where she addressed
lawmakers about the senate's renewal of
the violence against women act that's
why passing
this law is one of the most important
votes
u.s senators will cast this year
but when they're not taking on capitol
hill the kids are following mom on the
red carpet
[Applause]
last year the eternals press tour was a
family affair
angelina a red carpet fashionista for
decades told e.t it was therapeutic to
watch her kids have a fashion moment of
their own
i think the important thing is they
they've been
they haven't made a choice they've been
public sin for their whole lives and so
to try to find a way where they can
not be kind of overwhelmed by it but
just be in it in a comfortable way i'm
happy that they're able to to have some
fun with it and not take it too
seriously and
and start to explore themselves even
with their fashion
but when it comes to mom being a
superhero there was one thing they just
couldn't handle
[Music]
i heard your kids were shook by your
costume oh well i mean would you want to
see your mother wearing that
listen if you got it you got it i mean
your mom walks in in a full spandex gold
outfit with gold hair and you just think
what do you do for a living what are you
get back in your robe
[Music]